que nous commencions cette poursuite du
PLF
2024 avec ce matin l'examen des crédits
consacrés à l'enseignement agricole je
remercie monsieur le ministre d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce n'est pas la
première fois mais par contre je crois
que vous êtes un des premiers ministres
de l'Agriculture à venir aussi
assisument à chaque fois dans pour les
discussions du PLF donc on vous en
remercie évidemment très sincèrement euh
votre présence parmi nous au lendemain
l'examen du rapport de de Jacques
groperin sur les crédits de de
l'enseignement scolaire nous donne
l'occasion de témoigner de l'attachement
de notre commission à l'enseignement
agricole à sa diversité à sa place dans
notre système éducatif et au moyens
àouer à son fonctionnement cet
attachement du Sénat en général et de
notre commission en particulier à cette
spécificité française que représente
l'enseignement agricole n'est pas
nouveau nous avions eu l'occasion
notamment à travers le projet de loi de
finances 2021
de nous mobiliser assez fortement pour
alerter votre prédécesseur sur sur les
risques encourus par cet enseignement si
le schéma de rationalisation des moyens
et la trajectoire budgétaire envisagée à
l'époque par le gouvernement n'avait pas
été amendé par la voix de Nathalie de
lâre qui était à l'époque rapporteur
pour notre commission des des crédits de
l'enseignement agricole une mission
d'information sénatoriale avait élaboré
l'année suivante pas moins de 45
recommandations destiné à préserver je
je cite ce rapport un enseignement
agricole de qualité dans l'intérêt des
filières agricoles et alimentaires au
nom de la cohésion des territoire vous
aurez l'occasion monsieur le ministre de
nous indiquer dans quelques instants si
2 ans après la publication de ce
document Les les recommandations
relevant de votre compétence ont pu être
mis en œuvre et si les difficultés
identifiées à l'époque dont certaines
dont que nous avions identifié demeure
d'actualité je pense en particulier à à
la concurrence entre établissement de
l'enseignement agricole entre eux sur
certains territoires ainsi qu'à la
concurrence entre les formations
dispensé par ses établissements et ceux
de l'éducation nationale voire avec les
formations dispensées par certaines
officines du secteur privé lucratif pour
reprendre le terme de Stéphane Piednoir
au moment où l'apprentissage connaît une
progression spectaculaire vous aurez
sans doute également à cœur d'évoquer le
pacte d'avenir qui devait accompagner le
projet de loi d'orientation et d'avenir
agricole annoncé par président de la
République le 9 septembre 2022 que vous
aviez longuement détaillé devant nous
l'année dernière et et que je dois vous
avouer nous avons un pu un peu perdu de
de vue ce pacte devait en particulier
contenir un axe consacré à à à la
formation et à l'orientation des futur
professionnel du vivant nous serions
particulièrement intéressés par les
éléments que vous pourriez nous apporter
sur les résultats des différentes
concertation lancée à ce sujet au cours
de l'année 2023 monsieur le ministre je
ne serai pas plus long et vous propose
de d'organiser cette audition en trois
temps d'abord en vous laissant la parole
pour que vous nous présentiez les les
grandes lignes du du budget 2024
consacré à à l'enseignement et à la
recherche agricole ensuite je donnerai
la parole à Bernard
fialer qui est le rapporteur budgétaire
pour notre commission des crédits
enseignement technique agricole qui est
une une demi-journée particulièrement
intense puisqu'il sort de l'hémicycle où
il rapportait un une PPL et puis ainsi
qu'à Stéphane Piednoir et à Lord Arcos
qui ne sont pas encore
arrivés s'ils souhaitent prendre la
parole au titre de leur fonction à
l'OPEX je pense en donnant enfin la
parole aux autres collègues qui
souhaiteraient vous interroger sur les
crédits de votre ministère je rappelle
pour terminer que cette audition est
captée et diffusée en direct sur le site
du Sénat monsieur le ministre je vous
laisse la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci de votre
invitation je réponds effectivement
assez volontiers c'est c'est mieux quand
il y a de la continuité et je trouve que
c'est bien qu'on puisse faire à cette
occasion un point sur l'enseignement
agricole et sur le crédit qui sont
attachés je sais l'attachement du Sénat
ce système édcatif souvent méconnu
ou mal connu alors que sa pédagogie sa
contribution à l'émancipation de nos
jeunes l'engagement de ses équipes
éducatives et son rle l'essentiel pour
le renouvellement des générations en
agriculture et globalement pour le
secteur agricole et bien d'autres
secteur mérite d'être reconnu soutenu et
valorisé c'est aussi des établissements
présents sur le territoire pour ce qui
est du budget c'est un budget en haose
de 6,3% que je viens vous présenter sur
cette partie-là euh et qui une fois les
transferts de la mission enseignement
scolaire réalisé atteindra près de 10 %
ce qui est une Haus assez historique de
ces crédits je tiens Despré en Blu à
remercier la sénatrice de de l' du
travail qu'elle a fait son engagement en
plusieurs annués et à saluer votre
nouveau rapporteur Bernard fialer pour
la qualité des travaux qu'il a mené
l'enseignement agricole est un appareil
de formation moderne porteur de sens et
qu'il convient donc de consolider il
prépare une diversité de métiers propose
à cela une diversité de formation ça
prépare après de plus de 200 métiers les
métiers des filières agricoles et
agroalimentaires les métiers de la
filière fouretbois les métiers liés à la
préservation et à la mise en valeur des
milieux naturels les vétérinaires
l'entretien et la création d'aménagement
paysagés les services aux personnes
âgées ou la petite enfance en milieu
rural les services dans les territoires
le tourisme l'animation la communication
le commerce et la vente bref ça forme a
des métiers qui sont très présents sur
l'ensemble des territoires en
particulier évidemment les territoires
ruraux il reposeent en 2023 sur près de
800 établissements présents sur
l'ensemble du territoire métropolitain
ultramarin et il dispose donc et je sais
vous y êtes attentif d'un renignement
local et d'une capacité d'innovation et
d'expérimentation dans nos territoires
et je tiens à saligner des qualités des
relations avec les responsables de
l'enseignement qui soit public ou privé
et leur implication dans les grands
enjeux de l'enseignement agricole chacun
appte et joue un rôle singulier et
complémentaire et chacun reconnaît que
le rôle est complémentaire d'ailleurs
dans l'ensemble de l'enseignement
agricole l'année scolaire 202324 est
marqué par la poursuite de
l'augmentation globale du nombre de
jeunes qui suivent la formation de
l'enseignement agricole et c'est une
satisfaction dans une démographie
globale on en avait parlé je crois l'an
dernier déclinante le secteur de
l'enseignement agricole est un des rares
secteurs qui voit ses effectifs
légèrement progresser mais progress
c'est quand même par rapport au reste de
l'enseignement ça montre l'intérêt
qu'ont les jeunes générations pour ce
type d'enseignement sur le long cours
les effectifs totaux de l'enseignement
agricoolle augmente de manière constante
depuis 2018 avec 4,6 % d'élèves
d'étudiants et d'apprentis en plus entre
2019 et 2022 s'agissant spécifiquement
de l'enseignement agricole technique il
comptait en
2022 rentrée 2022 186000 élèves en
augmentation de 0,3 % par rapport à
l'année précédente et de 4 % par rapport
à 2019 c'est donc une dynamique qui est
enclenchée et on aura peut-être
l'occasion de revenir sur la question
des apprentis l'enseignement agricole
vaille au cheminement de chaque
apprenant c'est d'ailleurs une de ses
grandes forces je trouve à ceux qui ont
déjà un projet assez
défini il propose une formation adapté à
ceux qui cherchent une voix ou qui
cherchent leur voix pour vous dire les
choses plus simplement il propose tout
un éventail de possibilités et un
accompagnement très personnalisé je
vrais souligné l'attention toute
particulière que l'enseignement agricole
porte au plus modeste bien
qu'accueillant des élèves au profil
social moins globalement moins favorbl
que ceux de l'éducation nationale les
taux de réussite aux examens et les taux
d'insertion professionnel de ces élèves
sont régulièrement supérieurs à ceux de
l'éducation nationale comme l'a souligné
le rapport de 2021 de la Cour des
comptes sur le coût et la performance de
l'enseignement agricole technique je
vrais également insister sur le fait que
l'enseignement agricole veille à
l'engagement des jeunes tant dans la
classe que hors de la classe c'est un
accompagnement global avec la démarche
des codélégué et dans le cadre des
associations des lycéens étudiants
stagiaires et apprentis et des
associations sportives il propose un
enseignement sociocculturel et une
ouverture sur l'international qui sont
je crois reconnus l'enseignement
agricole technique dispose enfin d'un
budget de 2024 qui lui permet de
préparer l'avenir par l'innovation et la
formation de nos jeunes face au défis
majeurs de renouvellement des
générations en agriculture et de
l'adaptation au changement climatique en
effet le programme 143 dispose d'un
budget de 1,7 milliards d'euros en
augmentation de 100 millions par rapport
à la loi de finance initiale de 2023 le
transfert de 76,8 millions additionnels
au PLF 2024 depuis le P141 le programme
141 enseignement scolaire public du
second degré pour financer le pacte
enseignant portera la hausse réelle à
176 millions d'euros soit une
augmentation de 10 % marquant la
priorité donnée par le gouvernement et
globalement à l'éducation la première
priorité de ce budget donc en forte ha
c'est donc de renforcer l'attractivité
du métier je sais qu'il s'agit d'une
préoccupation qui sera exprimée par
votre rapporteur
ce PLF permet notamment de financer plus
de personnel leur cdisation et leur
rémunération il permet le renforcement
des équipes éducatives et de service de
médecine scolaire plus 20 + 20 ETP une
hausse conformément à la trajectoire
qu'on s'est donné dont on avait déjà
parlé ensemble monsieur le Président des
effectifs des aesh est prévu les
accompagnements des élèves en situation
de handicap ainsi que la revalorisation
de leur rémunération la cédisation de
223 ETPT d'aesh et c'est un élément
important le fait qui puisse être cdisé
et de 135 37 assistants d'éducation soit
360 équivalent temps plein la hausse du
point d'indice de la fonction publique
va concourir pour 10,6 millions d'euros
et les mesures bass salaire pour 6
millions d'euros s'ajoute à cela les
mesures du pacte enseignant qui seront
ajouté par transfert à ce PLF 2024 un
transfert à hauteur de 34 millions
d'euros permettra de financer la partie
socle du pacte enseignant soit
l'augmentation inconditionnelle des
enseignants et CPE et les mesures
d'amélioration de leur carrière ceci
correspond à une augmentation je le dis
et je le répète de 100 à 230 € net de
plus par mois pour les
enseignants bénéficiant de l'indemnité
de suivi et d'orientation et je le
répète sans condition c'est effectif
depuis la rentrée 2023 et c'est inédit
un autre transfert de 42 millions
d'euros pour la partie brique de pâac
pour les enseignants qui seront
volontaires de cette démarche or dans
l'enseignement agricole l'adhésion à des
missions de brique a été très importante
58 % des agents de l'enseignement
agricole c'est à signaler 53 % dans le
seul enseignement agricole public ont
souscrit au moins à une démission du
PACT chaque brique est rémunéré 1250
brut annuel au total 65 % des briques
disponibles ont été attribué et en
moyenne cela fait pour reprendre ce
schéma des briques 2,6 briques soit en
moyenne ça c'est le plus sonnant et
tribuchant 240 € mensuel en plus je
veuxer cette commission remercier les
équipes de direction qui ont qui ont et
continuent à accompagner la mise en
œuvre de ce pacte et remercier les
enseignants qui s'y sont engagés très
résolument le versement prochain de la
prime dédié aux directions prévu dans le
pacte enseignant reconnaîtra ce nouvel
engagement évidemment de leur part je
veux aussi redire ma détermination à
améliorer leur statut d'emploi par
ailleurs les discussions avec la DG AFP
sont en cours ce statut d'emploi
amélioré sera un élément durable de
l'attractivité de ces fonctions parfois
difficiles et éminentes de direction
priorité du budget renforcer la
protection de la santé et l'inclusion de
nos élèves chemin continue que nous
essons de mener depuis plusieurs années
qu'on essaie de poursuivre dans la durée
c'est la continuité de l'effort qui paye
dans ces cas-là 3,8 millions pour
revaloriser les assistants d'éducation
et le recrutement de 39 ETP d'assistant
d'éducation le renforcement de nos
équipes de médecine scolaire comme
évoqué précédemment le renforcement de
la lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
j'ai lancé un plan dédié conformément
aux annonces de la première ministre en
octobre 2023 construit sur un engagement
de longue date de l'enseignement
agricole ce nouveau plan renforce la
prévention la vigilance le traitement
des cas signalés les sanctions
évidemment aussi il généralise aussi
l'accès au 3018 pour tous dans
l'enseignement agricole par ailleurs
après une augmentation de 10,3 million
d'euros en 2023 notre politique d'école
inclusive verra son budget augmenté de
3,5 million d'euros en 2024
euh dont 7 07 sont déjà inscrits au PLF
et 2,8 seront l'objet d'un transfert en
gestion à partir du programme
230 la troisème priorité de renforcer
l'attractivité de l'enseignement
agricole pour les apprenants par les les
mesures prises je souhaiterais en mettre
trois en avant pour être rapide je suis
déjà sans doute un peu long mais le
budget de l'enseignement agricole
augmente de 66,7 million d'euros pour
financer laallocation des élèves de la
voie professionnelle comme l'a annoncé
le président de la République dans le
cadre de la réforme de la voie
professionnelle les semaines de stage
donneront lieu à cette à cette
allocation aux élèves de Ka et BacPro en
cette année
2324 et il sera opérant à partir de
début 2024 le ministère met en place la
rénovation de ces bacs professionnels je
veux juste en donner quelques éléments
certains d'entre vous m'ont saisi à ce
sujet comme l'ont fait certains
syndicats ce travail de rénovation
pédagogique a été lancé dès 2020 soumis
à nos instances à partir de 2021 et ces
bac pro rénovés se mettent en place en
classe de première en cette rentrée sur
le fond cette rénovation poursuit un but
pédagogique renforcer les temps
permettant aux élèves d'appréhender les
compétences dans une approche globale et
de manière concertée il s'agit en
particulier d'étend d'enseignement en
pluridisciplinarité c'est-à-dire
intervention conjointe de deux
enseignants de deux disciplines
différentes face aux élèves par exemple
mathématiques et agronomie et je pense
que c'est très utile cela se traduit
concrètement par une semaine de plus de
stage collectif plus d'enseignants
invités à faire des cours en peie
disciplinarité une semaine d' blanche en
plus pour que les équipes puissent
adapter leur modalités d'enseignement et
d'accompagnement des élèves ou préparer
cette intervention en pluri les projets
qui vont avec évidemment l'évolution des
grilles horaires et du décompte des
heures de plury entraîne des réactions
de certains syndicats de personnel je
veux déjà vous indiquer que cette
rénovation de bac pro ne se fait pas
avec moins de dotation horair pour les
enseignements mais au contraire avec
légèrement plus il n donc pas de
recherche d'économie vis-à-is des
enseignements c'est assez facilement
démontrable et donc de leur rémunération
l'objectif est bien un objectif
pédagogique il y a en effet et ceci dit
il faut aussi l'assumer des changements
de grille horaire et de l'organisation
des semaines de cours des semaines de
stage et des semaines blanches certaines
semaines font l'objet d'un décompte
précis des horaires d'autres non et donc
certaines fiches de service ont évolué
vous l'aurez compris ce nouvel équilibre
concis pour une seule raison améliorer
la formation un moyen constant voire
avec un peu plus nécessite d'être mieux
explicité mieux accompagné je m'y
emploirai avec le souci avec mon
directeur de la dgel avec le souci du
dialogue pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions aplanir les choses et j'ai
rencontrer certains d'entre eux sur le
terrain ce weekend et je me suis engagé
à pouvoir les rencontrer pour expliciter
et démontrer ce que nous faisons enfin
le met en place la rénovation de ces
bacs professionnels ce travail de
rénovation a été lancé dès 2020 soumis
là aussi à nos instances donc ça c'est
les éléments je pardon excusez-moi je je
redisais deux fois la même chose
l'évolution des gruilles horaires va se
faire dans ce cadre là et donc je disais
on va essayer de revoir avec les
syndicats qui sont concernés qui sont en
émotion enfin ce budget poursuit pardon
notre engagement en terme d'orientation
et d'attractivité campagne communication
aventure du vivant alors je ne sais pas
si c'est ça qui a produit l' activité
des métiers mais en tout cas
reconnaissons que depuis qu'elle a été
lancée l'attractivité vers les
formations qui mène à ces métiers de
l'enseignement et les métiers du vivant
est un élément très important et donc je
voudrais annoncer aussi que
l'agriculture et l'agroalimentaire et
ces métiers ont été mis au cœur des pr
priorités de la Convention Cadre
relative à la découverte des métiers
pour les collégiens des classes de 5e 4e
3e qui sera signé par les différents
ministres concneré région de France
prochainement et enfin dernière priorité
et ça me permet de répondre à cette
question là placé au cœur de la
loi et du pacte d'orientation et de
transition pour le renouvellement des
générations vous l'avez évoqué 7 mois de
travail un certain nombre de
préconisation et qui seront poursuivis
la première ministre annoncera dans les
semaines qui viennent avec moi
évidemment ce pacte et cette loi
d'orientation il y a plus avoir le
sentiment vous avez raison monsieur le
Président qu' avait un temps de silence
d'une certaine façon le travail s'est
poursuivi nous continuons à le
travailler évidemment sur les bases de
ce que nous avons dit qui était les
bases de la découverte des métiers de
l'orientation vers les métiers de la
facilitation à l'entrée dans ces métiers
de l'évolution pédagogique et avec un
enjeu majeur pour nous qui est un enjeu
de faciliter l'intégration dans ses
métiers dans toutes les formes de
métiers et de de préparer les grandes
transitions on a besoin de former des
jeunes qui en situation d'exploitant
agricole ou en situation de salariés
dans les métiers de l'agriculture puisse
se préparer au défi immense qui est
celui de la
transition écologique de la transition
climatique et d'ailleurs au final de la
transition des transitions économique
évidemment l'accélération des
transitions qui s'impose nécessite des
compétences nouvelles pour les futurs
professionnels le pacte et les lois
comportera donc des mesures de
découverte de l'agriculture
d'orientation au collège et au lycée de
création de contrats locaux autour des
établissements pour relancer les
formations la création d'un Bachelor
bac+ 3 agro qui vient combler un manque
on l'avait évoqué je crois monsieur le
Président dernier pour attirer et
permettre d'accompagner la montée en
compétence de création d'un processus
massif de formation continue des
enseignants des formateurs et des
conseillers parce qu'il faut former nos
jeunes il faut former aussi les
formateurs c'est un élément évidemment
déterminant et parce qu'ils souhaitent
pour beaucoup d'entre eux préparer et
mieux accompagner leurs apprenants et
les agriculteurs ou les futurs
Agriculteurs de France mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrice
monsieur le Président vous l'aurez
compris je crois ce budget est une étape
importante pour reconnaître l'engagement
des équipes éducatives protéger et
accompagner les apprenants consolider un
système qui marche il permet à
l'enseignement agricole de se préparer à
être un outil déterminant pour relever
les grands défis de souveraineté de
cette décennie que représente le
renouvellement des générations et les
transitions écologiques et climatique
merci monsieur le Président
merci Bernard fieller rapporteur des
crédits budgétaires pour la commission
merci monsieur le Président donc
monsieur le ministre vous avez insisté
he sur l'attractivité du métier ma
première question moi c'est que à la
rentrée 2023 certes le nombre d'élèves
est légèr en hausse ça c'est surtout dû
au succès de l'apprentissage et mais 1 %
environ des effectifs parant depuis 5
ans mais la nécessité c'est 30
% d'ici 2030 pour répondre au
renouvellement des des génération en
agriculture alors est-ce qu'il y a des
actions supplémentaires qui vont être
proposées pour continuer à à poursuivre
un petit peu l'attractivité comme ça des
filières de l'enseignement technique
agricole et si on attire les il faut
aussi faire face au difficultés de
recrutement hein auquel l'enseignement
agricole à faire face comme
l'enseignement d'ailleurs en
général ça va demander un nombre
d'enseignants supplémentaires d'autant
qu'il y a plutôt des petits effectifs he
dans dans l'enseignement agricole et
quelle mesure donc envisagez-vous
au-delà du du du pacte enseignant pour
répondre à cette crise d'attractivité
par exemple pour certaines disciplines
techniques et professionnelles est-ce
que la voie dérogatoire pour permettre
le recrutement d'enseignants simplement
niveauac+ 3 licences alors que
actuellement on est sur bac plus 5 qui
pose je crois des problèmes de
recrutement sur des formations technique
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui qui
va être mise en place enfin est-ce que
vous pouvez ai nous faire un point sur
les les implications euh euh qui vont
être des travaux qui vont être menés
dans la loi de orientation agricole
est-ce qu'il y a des des crédits
supplémentaires qui vont venir abonder
le programme 143 en 2024 pour la mise en
œuvre de cette réforme et puis vous
annonciez la la semaine dernière que les
agriculteurs sinistrés en en novembre
par les les tempêtes et inondations en
Bretagne en Normandie dans l'au- de
France pourront bénéficier d'un fond de
de 80 millions d'euros est-ce qu'il y a
des établissements deenseignement
agricole qui ont été touchés par ces
intempéries et est-ce qui sont euh
éligible justement à à ce fond puisqu'il
y a des des exploitations agricoles dans
ces ces établissements et puis on la DGR
nous avait précisé que le nombre
d'étudiants par exemple si vous parliez
de du succès de du l'enseignement
agricole et des échanges internationaux
avec pourtant simplement pour 2 % notre
total d'étudiants il y en a quand même 9
% qui bénéficient des crédits euh
Erasmus euh vous savez qu'on vient de
parler de la loi projet de loi
immigration et est-ce que la la
coopération qui se fait avec des pays
euh entre autres les pays africains ù
qui nous envoie beaucoup de réfugiés
climatiques justement parfois par manque
de de
ressources lié à des nouvelles pratiques
euh agro agrocultural donc peuvent
bénéficier quel quel est le le le le par
partenariat qui pourrait être fait
justement dans dans cette coopération
sur l'enseignement des des nouvelles
techniques que queon maîtrise parfois
chez nous il y a aussi le le l'impact du
de la hausse du coût de
l'énergie certains établissements nous
ont parler de plus de 500 % de frais
dans certains établissements et et et
les enseignes les l'enseignement privé
catholique entre autres qui bénéficient
pas forcément partout de participation
des régions et que ils sont obligés
d'augmenter les frais pour les familles
alors que 45 % de leurs élèves sont sont
sont
[Musique]
boursiers vous avez aussi cité parler du
problème de de l'école inclusive alors
si dans le public il y a des aesh dans
le privé c'est des
AVS mais qui ont un statut moins
attractif euh et moins moins pérenne
est-ce que on pourra envisager d'ouvrir
la possibilité à ces établissements de
bénéficier d'aesh et puis enfin dernière
question plus générale c'est que
l'agronomie donc ensemble des sciences
exactes naturell économique et social
nécessaire pour pratiquer et comprendre
l'agriculture a été retiré de
l'enseignement général de la filière
agricole et désormais ce n'est plus
qu'une option je cis et certaines voies
parmi les syndicats de l'enseignement
agricole public s'en sont ému donc
est-ce que envisagé de de rouvrir
ces ces options pour justement la
formation des des chefs d'entreprise
dont on aura d'entreprise agricole dont
notre pays aura
besoin cette première série de questions
est assez nombreuse et mais précise
merci monsieur le rapporteur d'abord la
question de l'attractivité des métiers
et l'attractivité de l'enseignement
agricole oui une grande part mais pas
seulement pas retiré par le par les
questions d'apprentissage alors on a je
vous fais une réponse en deux temps la
première vous dites il faut plus 30 %
enfin il faut former plus 30 %
d'agriculteurs tous les gens qui vont
dans l'enseignement agricole ne se
destinent pas donc il faut dans le
pardon le le vivier j'allais dire un
vile un mot dans le vivier des gens qui
sont déjà dans l'enseignement à école
faire en sorte qu'on essaie de les
encourager aller vers les métiers de
chef d'exploitant
agricoes et pas peut-être aller vers des
métiers où alors je sais pas s'il y a
pas des besoins aussi mais une partie du
travail doit être fait là me semble-til
deuxième élément c'est ce que j'ai dit
on a besoin de continuer à travailler
c'est ce qu'on porte dans la dans le
pacte d'avenir et lois d'orientation de
travailler sur découverte des métiers
attractivité des métiers c'est un défi
he plus 30 mais ça peut pas être que du
net plus en enseignement agricole c'est
aussi à l'intérieur de l'enseignement
agricole qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
encadrager nos
jeunes à à travailler sur cette question
et donc c'est un processus de découverte
et une orientation des un processus
national qui sera proposé dans le pacte
et dans la loi avec une découverte moi
je je suis certain que la découverte au
collège est parfois je sais pas si elle
est tardive mais elle est pas suffisante
je pense que la découverte très
tôtd dans l'enseignement priv il faut
trouver les voies et moyens c'est
parfois techniquement un peu compliqué
la découverte très tôt est un élément
central d'attractivité du
métier nous avons désormais des des
populations qui vivent principalement
dans les villes et donc ce qui était une
découverte un peu du quotidien de la vie
de tous les jours ne l'est plus et donc
on a besoin de travailler dès le plus
jeune âge sur cette question là et on a
besoin de penser ce qui est une deuxième
révolution que la plupart des jeunes ou
d'ailleurs moins jeunes qui vont
s'installer dans les métiers de
l'agriculture chef d'exploitation autre
ne seront pas du tout du tout issu du
monde
agricole et c'est là qui notre
vivier et c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera
à retrouver des gens dans ces métiers à
renouveler génération et puis évidemment
des stages massifs dans tous les
secteurs au collège ça nécessite que
d'ailleurs nous constituons quelque
chose de l'ordre d'accueillance pour des
stagiaires donc c'est le travail que
nous voulons faire avec les en
particulier les Chambres d'agriculture
pour faire en sorte que on on sache on
peut envoyer des jeunes qui auraient
envie d'aller faire des stages dans les
dans les collèges dans les dans des
stages au niveau collège évidemment la
communication qui est important alors il
y a un deuxième sujet crise
d'attractivité ça c'est des apprenants
puis criseattractivité des métiers de
l'enseignement vous l'avez dit monsieur
le rapporteur c'est c'est assez global
euh comme les autres nous participons au
travail de de de revalorisation c'est
l'objet du pacte enseignant en partie
hein euh mais deux c'est la même crise y
compris d'identité qui peut être posée
sur la question agricole c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut qu'on qu'on dise en quoi le
métier d'enseignant agricole est un
métier d'avenir est un métier porteur de
sens alors ça l'est déjà mais il me
semble qu'il faut qu'on aille plus loin
donc le pacte enseignant vise aussi à ça
par la rémunération mais la rémunération
est une chose mais aussi le sens qu'on
donne aux choses la manière s'organise
l'enseignement agricole c'est un élément
de l'attractivité euh euh me semble-t-il
et sur lequel nous allons travailler
alors après on est on essaie de
travailler euh et de d'innover en
recrutant au niveau licence et on joue
en interne en en une et on forme en
interne en master pour pour avoir de
nouveaux enseignants qui nous permettent
de travailler sur ces questions quelques
mots sur vous m'avez parlé est-ce que la
loi ou le pacte alors une grande partie
des moyens ils sont quand même déjà
budgetés parce que
je je j'ai du mal à dire qu'ayant un
budget en hausse globale de près de 20 %
lui-même en hausse globale par rapport à
l'année précédente de 6 ou 700 millions
il faudrait encore vous voyez ce que je
veux dire je pense que la question c'est
comment on déploie tout ça s'il a s'il y
avait des besoins complémentaires on
verra ce qui est ce qui est ce qu'on a
essayé de construire dans le pacte et la
loi c'est de ne pas attendre le pacte ou
la loi pour avoir les éléments
budgétaires ce qui est un peu parfois
peut surprendre mais je trouve que c'est
mieux comme une grande partie c'est du
PACT pas de dire on va attendre encore
une année et perdre une année donc
l'idée c'était de gagner du temps en
moyen budgétaire et le PACT et la loi
viendront montrer la cohérence
d'ensemble de de ce de ce travail après
sur la question vous avez évoqué sur la
question de l'école inclusive c'est vrai
à trat tout droit public av vs c'est
d'une une autre donc il est impossible
d'avoir des contrats de droit public
dans privé mais des
améliorations qui ont été faites sur les
aesh on voocation à tre porté euh pour
les autres qui sont sous autres statut
et donc c'est un chantier qui est ouvert
mais vous avez raison de souligner qu'il
faut qu'on pense les deux accompagnement
pour pas que l'un et l'autre soit le
léser sur ces sujets là sur la question
alors question des intempéries euh oui
peut y avoir alors bâti assez peu toute
façon c'est assuré enfin bref tout ça
c'est assez documenté h làas si je peux
dire il peut y avoir des dégâts sur les
exploitations dans certains cas
évidemment ça sera
pris je crois pas que ce soit c'est
autre chose que le budget des 80
millions que j'ai annoncé qui sont
plutôt destinés vraiment au secteur
agricole directement touché mais de
toute façon nous en avons la
responsabilité évidemment il faut que ce
soit couvert il me semble que c'est un
élément très important sur la
coopération avec les pays notamment ceux
qui sont en difficulté contenu nous
aussi hein mais plus que nous peut-être
du fait du dérèglement climatique il y a
beaucoup de projets qui sont en cours de
coopération c'est une tradition du
l'enseignement agricole et donc ça va se
poursuivre euh peut-être que ça vaudra
le coup de vous en faire un point plus
précis même hein mais et que le débat
pourrait être l'occasion de le faire
mais un autre on travaille avec le
Sénégal la Côte d'Ivoire l'Angola enfin
bref on a beaucoup de programmes de
coopération dans une logique de
connaissance et qu'on connaît
habituellement aussi dans une logique de
de formation pour que des générations de
jeunes dans ces pays-là puissent
puissent avoir des
éléments là-dessus impact du coup
énergie euh c'est vrai que dans il peut
y avoir quelques difficultés euh euh on
a on a on a aidé les affaires autour de
avec le Fond de Roulement mais c'est pas
une solution pérenne évidemment et donc
on va travailler sur l'année 2024 pour
regarder et ajuster on avait une année
2023 qui était une année un peu sans
qu'on sache comment tout ça allait
atterrir on commence à y voir mieux et
donc les choses et donc le travail va se
poursuivre dans ces affaires là j'en
finis juste par la question de
l'agronomie en option euh
[Musique]
oui l'enseignement agricole fait de
l'agronomie enfin globalement il fait de
l'agronomie partout parce que à chaque
fois on se pose la question et en fait
plus encore plus avec 72 % de
référentiel revu pour intégrer
l'agroécologie l'agroécologie c'est
l'agronomie hein mais c'est l'agronomie
qui s'oriente vers la transition
euh et puis l'enseignementécole est le
seul je le signale au passage à faire en
filière générale une une bac général
donc une biologie écologie en spécialité
et donc à par les agronomie en filière
générale et donc c'est une spécificité
donc il me semble que sur ce sujet là on
est plutôt bien avancé voilà ce que je
voulais vous
dire merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour déjà ses
réponses alors quelques questions
complémentaires en novembre
2023 une centaine d'enseignants ont
signifié leur mécontentement par rapport
à ce qu'il disaient leur slogan c'était
travailler plus pour gagner autant donc
et il remettait en question la méthode
de calcul qui avait été mise en
application sur 30 %
des régions académiques et généralisé
donc maintenant alors que répondez-vous
à ces enseignants et comment
comptez-vous expliquer cette nouvelle
méthode de de calcul pour ces
enseignants vous vous en avez déjà parlé
le le harcèlement scolaire pouvez-vous
nous dire si la manière d'aborder le
harcèlement
scolaire est différente puisque on le
sait l'enseignement agricole est une
échelle différente de l'enseignement
général et donc est-ce que les outils
doivent être adaptés à l'enseignement
agricole et est-ce que le phénomène est
aussi massif
ensuite évidemment les budgets sont à la
hausse le nombre de jeunes qui s'orient
vers ces filières est aussi assez
positif donc lorsqu'on parle de AVS ou
àesh en réalité sur l'attractivité il y
a une question sur l'attractivité du
métier sur sur la rémunération du métier
vous y avez déjà répondu mais il y a une
question aussi sur le nombre d'élèves
accueillis donc pouvez-vous nous
préciser le nombre d'élèves accueillis
et du du coup s'il y a plus de d'AVS en
réalité s'il y a plus d'élèves
accueillis aussi on l'a bien vu dans le
budget enseignement scolaire parfois une
augmentation de budget ou une
augmentation de personnel cache pas
forcément un accueil qualitatif je
voudrais revenir aussi sur les MFR les
Maisons familiales rurales euh il y a
une négociation je crois qui est en
cours avec la DG qui semble a priori
selon les auditions que nous avons pu
mener avec le rapporteur s'orienter vers
un échec semble-t-il euh et donc l'objet
de cette négociation c'est de de revenir
sur l'aide par élève donc à partir du
moment où cette aide par élève euh à
destination des Maisons Familiales
Rurales serait un échec euh cette année
pour le budget 2024 pouvez-vous prendre
l'engagement pour que 2025 on voit
véritablement une aide revue c'est un
réseau qui est extrêmement développé sur
mon territoire et qui répond à une une
demande importante euh pour finir je
voudrais évoquer le camion du vivant euh
puisque on sait que des millions ils
sont consacrés et nous avons pu
constater au cours de nos audition un
certain scepticisme quand même sur le
rapport l'investissement et la réalité
de l'efficacité puisque un certain
nombre de personnes qui étaient
présentes aux auditions disaient nous on
l'a jamais vu donc euh c'était une une
question d'efficacité par rapport au
budget monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie alors je vais prendre toutes
vos questions comme ça ça permettra au
ministres de de faire des recroupements
éventuellement Marie-Pierre Bonier merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi je rebondis sur deux
questions de mes collègues à laquelle
vous avez répondu partiellement sur
l'agroéconomie et parce que l'agronomie
tout simplement parce que vraiment en
audition ça nous a ceux qui nous ont
interpellé c'est ceux qui enseignent
donc il y a peut-être vraiment un
véritable sujet à creuser et je
rebondirai sur la question d'anque
billon portant sur l'évolution des des
fiches de service parce que avec cette
évolution pour soit ils ont des heures
supplémentaires qui perdent les
enseignants et pour eux ça vraiment ça
revient à travailler plus pour gagner
autant c'est vraiment mal perçu et vous
l'avez souligné il y a quand même un
problème d'attractivité salariale et
d'attractivité j'ai envie de dire de
l'enseignement général que ce soit en
général ou en en en enseignement
agricole donc vraiment il faut peut-être
vous avez dit que vous avez rencontré ce
weekend des membres de de l'enseignement
agricole enfin des enseignants il faut
vraiment revoir ce sujet parce que c'est
c'est pas pas vraiment pas bien perçu là
non plus et que concrètement ils ont V
un changement et je rejoins la question
d'Anie qui est partie sur le fait est-ce
que vous allez ce nouveau mode de calcul
qui concerne actuellement la pludisci
disciplinarité excusez-moi je me su un
professionnel a-t-il vocation de se
généraliser à l'ensemble des heures de
pluridisciplinarité des diplômes
deenseignement agricole la deuxième
question est très spécifique c'est euh
vous savez qu'il y a eu ça concerne les
lycées maritimes il y a la loi de 2002-
1574 qui prévoit la possibilité de
cdiser les aesh au bout de 3 ans or le
ministère de la transition écologique
dont dépend le lycée maritime ne tire
pas la même interprétation de la loi et
donc concrètement les abessages qui
exercent dans ces lycées atteignant ces
3 ans d'ancienneté ne sont pas
réembaucher et donc pas cdiser le
ministère préférant recruter un CDD
est-ce que vous pouvez être en lien
parce que là c'est aussi une demande qui
m'a été remonté est-ce qu'il est prévu
de remédier à cette inéquité de
traitement entre enseignement agricole
enseignement
maritime je je reste sur les
aesh donc en ce qui concerne
l'enseignement agricole pouvez-vous me
faire un retour de l'application de la
cédisation je crois que ça concernait
environ 300 asesh à la rentrée ça
concernait environ 300 as à la rentrée
sur les près de 800 que compte à
l'enseignement agricole ces asesh
désormais ne dépendent plus donc des
établissements les exercent mais du
ministère de l'Agriculture est-ce que
vous avez suffisamment de ressources
humaines pour répondre à cette évolution
parce que je sais que ça a été un sujet
aussi dans l'éducation nationale et
enfit je terminerai par les postes moyen
humains vous avez précisé qu'en effet
qu'il a il y a plus 20 ETP en ce qui
concerne service médecine scolaire et et
et services sociaux mais je tiens à
rappeler quand même que donc ça veut
dire pas de création de postees
d'enseignant alors vous parlez d'un
effectif d'élèves qui est quand même une
augmentation et et je rappelle qu'il y a
eu quand même 316 emplois qui ont été
supprimés entre 2017 et 2022 donc ça me
pose
question Gérard
lailleec merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci d'avoir
rappelé les les enjeux et comme je viens
de Bretagne j'ai peut-être des raisons
supplémentaires de m'attarder sur ces
enjeux s'agissant de
l'agriculture et euh je privilégierai
évidemment mon
questionnement sur les objets de
formation agricole mais d'emblé je
voudrais dire ici que il me semble que
nous avons besoin d'une très grande
ambition publique une très grande
ambition publique à la fois pour réussir
les mutations en cours donc il y a une
ambition en matière de contenu de
formation ce qui n'est pas l'objet de
notre réunion de ce matin et puis nous
avons besoin de cette grande ambition
publique je le dis aussi dans notre
région sans dresser l'enseignement privé
contre l'enseignement public au
contraire je pense que nos
établissements publics ne bénéficient
pas forcément des mêmes moyens que nos
établissements privés lorsque l'on met
les choses en comparaison en tout cas ça
réhausse me semble-t-il la
responsabilité publique et il vous aura
pas échappé que dans une région comme la
nôtre nous recherchons aussi dans nos
territoires
des solutions pour
conforter l'objet de ces formations je
pense notamment à ce que nous sommes en
train de mettre en place un GP
regroupant l'ensemble des lycées publics
ce qui est une manière à mon avis de
commencer à répondre au-delà des
questions budgétaires
elles-mêmes s'agissant du budget je
pense que l'appréciation d'un budget ne
vaut que en rapportant ce budget aux
objectifs qu'on poursuit donc évidemment
en soit il est positif la progression
dont vous avez pointé évidemment
l'augmentation sensible est un élément
positif les efforts particuliers qui
sont produits dans le secteur
médico-social pour aller très vite mérit
d'être pointer plus 20 ETP à rajoutter
au
10 du budget précédent c'est plutôt
positif je ne sais pas quel est le sort
qui a été réservé au 10 précédents
peut-être ont-ils été créé peut-être
n'a-t-il pas été possible de relever le
défi totalement je je ne sais pas vous
pourriez nous le dire et puis enfin sur
l'attractivité des métiers un peu comme
les deux mes deux collègues
précédentes évidemment nous sommes
interpellés sur cette question du
réajustement du temps de travail qui
manifestement suscite pas mal d'émotions
et de questionnement en tout cas ça
n'est pas perçu d'emblé comme une
avancée en tout cas l'appropriation par
la profession euh n'est pas n'est pas
celle-ci par conséquent tout éclairage
qui nous
permettrait bien de répondre au
questionnement dont nous pouvons être
l'objet constituerait évidemment un un
un point d'appui et d'autre part je
pense que si ce sujet pouvait être
surmonté et résolu ça constituerait un
élément important de la crédibilité de
l'attractivité dont je parlais à
l'instant merci je n'en dis pas plus
merci monsieur le président Martin
levrier merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le ministre pour tous vos
propos quelques questions rapides
d'abord sur l'apprentissage vous avez
parlé du développement de
l'apprentissage ma première question est
est-ce que ce développement se fait de
de la même façon que sur les autres
formes d'apprentissage c'estàd beaucoup
plus sur le postebac que sur le prébac
et si oui comment faire pour améliorer
le prébac si non tant mieux pouvez-vous
nous expliquer les
recettes même chose chose vous avez
parlé de la plu ah j'aris pas à le dire
pluriisciplinarité voilà je vais essayer
de pas le reprononcer celui-là est-ce
que dans la loi sur l'apprentissage à
l'origine il y avait une volonté de
créer des des UFA ou des CFA liés au
lycée professionnel est-ce que dans
l'agriculture ça s'est vraiment
développé est-ce que c'est une piste de
développement aussi en particulier dans
le prébac et qui aiderait à la plurie
j'arrête autre point vous vous parliez
de de l'attractivité et et vous
expliquer que le vivier le plus
important aujourd'hui était plutôt dans
le monde urbain pour attirer des jeunes
urbains à venir vers vers l'agriculture
est-ce que dans ces pistolat et dans le
budget il est prévu une logique vers le
vers les internats parce qu'on peut se
poser la question de faire venir les
jeunes dans la ruralité c'est un peu
difficile quand même de créer des farmes
au milieu de Paris donc comment faire
venir et est-ce que l'internat est une
piste ouverte ou pas et puis dernier
point presque sous forme d'humour vous
avez démontré la capacité de des
enseignants de du monde agricole de de
s'approprier les briques dans le pacte
DEP puis plus de 52 % si j'ai bien
compris ce qui est un grand succès par
rapport à j'allais dire une certaine
frilosité dans dans l'éducation
nationale quelle est votre recette
est-ce que c'est à base de carotes ou
pour pour aider l'enseignement
l'éducation nationale à avancer sur ce
sujet
merci euh Monique de Marco
pardon merci bonjour monsieur le
ministre moi j'ai une question simple je
suis là
au regard de l'importance et des enjeux
de la future loi d'orientation et
d'avenir agricole comment allez-vous
mettre en place et surtout renforcer
l'enseignement de la grroécologie
paysane et de l'agriculture biologique
au cœur des programmes de l'enseignement
agricole je voudrais que vous précisiez
un petit peu que ce soit pas une option
que ce soit quelque chose qui soit
est-ce que cons renforcer cet
[Musique]
enseignement colombe
brossell merci merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président Monsieur le le ministre euh
deux sujets le premier je je continue à
tirer le fil sur la création vous en
avez parlé dans votre propos
introductif de postes médicauxsoaux
euh trois questions précises sur ces
créations de postes qui sont pour le
coup une bonne nouvelle par rapport au
au budget de l'enseignement que nous
avons pu
examiner la première il y avait des déjà
eu des créations de postes au budget de
l'année dernière quelle est la
proportion de postes qui ont réellement
qui sont réellement aujourd'hui occupés
en gros est-ce que il y a création de
postes mais il n'y a pas d'adulte
derrière 2è question la
particularité de ces professionnels dans
l'enseignement agricole c'est d'avoir
des des trajets des temps de des distan
entre les différents établissements dans
lesquels il et elle travaillent plus
important que en moyenne que dans
l'enseignement public non agricole
est-ce que ce sujet fait partie des
sujets sur la table en terme de
mutualisation en terme de réorganisation
pour concourir à une meilleure
attractivité de ces postes et vous aurez
compris que il y a évidemment un lien
avec ma ma première
question et puis dernière question
est-ce qu' n'est complètement farfelu
d'imaginer des mutualisations avec
l'Éducation nationale parce que on peut
avoir des proximités d'établissement
avec des tutelles qui ne sont pas les
mêmes
mais plutôt que de fonctionner en sino
d'avoir un mode de fonctionnement qui
reparte du territoire et de la
géographie et de la capacité à exercer
son métier et puis deuxè question sur
les bourses sur critères
sociaux le
budget en
2024 s'élève à 44 millions d'euros et il
est en baisse par rapport à l'année
dernière alors nous avons eu exactement
le même échange avec votre collègue
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
dont le budget sur les les bourses sur
critères sociaux est en baisse qui
répond baisse de la démographie je me
permets de d'avoir un avis sur
l'Opportun é politique de faire des
économies quand un Français sur trois
déclare ne pas arriver à à manger à sa
fin mais en ce qui concerne votre budget
vous nous dites légère hausse
démographique du coup je n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment avec une légère
hausse démographique un profil d'élèves
dont vous avez d'ailleurs vous-même
rappelé dans votre propos introductif
que il ntait plus faible
économiquement que le le profil moyen
des élèves de l'éducation nationale
comment est-ce qu'on est explique une
baisse du budget sur critères sociaux
avec un peu plus d'élèves et des
difficultés de vie quotidiennes qui sont
elles croissantes merci pour votre
réponse vos réponses Catherine main de
sailli merci monsieur le Président
j'élargi le champ des questions à la
coopération menée avec les régions dont
la compétence est bien sûr d'assurer
aussi euh le financement des
infrastructures des établissements mais
aussi l'orientation et monsieur le
ministre vous avez souligné à quel point
il était important que ces jeunes soient
bien formés et orientés sont des métiers
d'avenir quand on songe aussi au défi
qui est notre souveraineté alimentaire
et puis après tout les régions elles
sont aussi en charge du devenir de de de
ce secteur des exploitations agricoles
qui retrouvent repreneur et du la
politique agricole et de la pêche en
général donc comment coopérez-vous et
comment s'organise notamment ce cette
étape très importante qui est
l'orientation
et enfin Karine
daniel Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre sur la question des
emplois dédiés mais mais pas forcément
pourvu on peut aussi élargir la question
au CPE parce qu'il y avait eu des des
postes fléchés et et voilà c'est une
question qui nous paraît aussi
importante pour la cohésion dans les
établissements moi je vais plutôt vous
interroger sur les questions qui
concernent l'enseignement supérieur et
la re cherche on a beaucoup parlé de la
question de de l'accès des élèves
boursiers à à
l'enseignement
agricole euh j'élargis cette question à
à au volet enseignement supérieur et la
recherche et au décrochage qu'il y a
visiblement entre les établissements
publics et les établissements privés
euh donc il y a pas les mêmes conditions
d'accueil des des étudiants susceptible
d'être boursiers ils n'ont par exemple
pas accès dans toutes les formations à
l'aide à la mobilité internationale euh
ça me paraît important de de traiter
cette question euh d'équité parce qu'on
sait aussi que les établissements privés
évidemment sous contrat d'intérêt
général contribuent à à à la couverture
territoriale de l'enseignement agricole
dans les différentes régions et et et on
sait aussi que des étudiants de de
conditions modestes euh suivent ces
formations
deuxè question sur le sur le volet
enseignement sup la loi sur
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
avait ouvert à la possibilité d'ouvrir
des formations vétérinaires pour des
établissements privés donc il y a une
première école je crois qui a répondu à
à cette à cette
possibilité la salle
Bovet est-ce que vous avez une
évaluation une première évaluation de de
des effets de cette ouverture où en sont
les accréditations européennes sur ce
type de formation et comment se
positionne aujourd'hui le ministère de
l'agriculture sur
d'éventuelles consolidation ou ou
nouvelles ouvertures ou bien évaluation
de cette nouvelle possibilité merci
enfin je l'avais oublié Michel logier
non non je me suis juste ajouté à la fin
donc pas oublié monsieur le Président
merci en tout cas monsieur le ministre
savoir est-ce que comme dans
l'enseignement général les
établissements
agricoles connaissent certains problèmes
d'insécurité de comportement des des
élèves du respect des enseignants du
respect des valeurs de notre public du
port de certaines tenues vestimentaires
alors est-ce que vous avez mis certains
moyens en place pour
ceci voilà je crois que tous ceux qui
voulaient s'exprimer l'ont fait monsieur
le ministre je voula Laesser répondre à
ces différentes questions certaines se
recoupent notamment sur les
négociations merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
vais peut-être commencer sur la question
qui est revenue de façon assez régulière
sur la
question du temps de travail des des des
des des enseignants qui s'émeuvent un
peu de la modification alors d'abord je
répète les choses il n'y a pas
d'augmentation du temps de
travail enfin c'est c'est un fait comme
disait comme disait l'autre et les faits
sont ttus bon deuxème élément il y a une
réorganisation du temps travail mais le
volume horaire même c'est c'est donc
faut pas qu'on dise c'est travailler
plus pour gagner autant c'est c'est
travailler autant et différemment pour
gagner autant mais je répète ce que j'ai
dit donc c'est juste pour dire que c'est
bien la volonté je le répète il y a pas
d'économie budgétaire làdessus donc
c'est pas notre sujet on s'en fiche en
fait c'est pas c'est pas fait pour ça
mais reconnaissons que l'évolution de la
PAI pédagogie ça peut pas être un
intangible en disant c'est comme ça
depuis 2004 ou c'est peut-être quelque
chose comme ça il faudrait pas le bouger
alors après je peux comprendre que ça ça
puiss changer des choses et qui a besoin
de comprendre alors quand je dis il faut
faire de la pédagogie c'est pas je vous
écoute et je fais comme j'ai dit c'est
on fait de la pédagogie pour bien
détailler regarder expliquer montrer
comment ça se passe mais moi je n'en
pardon je le dis c'est compliqué d'en
rabattre sur la question pédagogique
c'est d'abord une question pédagogique
et donc on va on va en parler avec les
syndicats qui sont concerné ça a été dit
par la sénatrice billon SS 100 à 200
agents donc c'est pas c'est pas quelque
chose de massif mais c'est pas parce que
c'est pas massif que j'en tiens pas
compte et que j'écoute pas mais il faut
qu'on comprenne bien que la volonté
pédagogique elle restera parce qu'on a
besoin de faire la
pluridisciplinarité plus que jamais y
compris pour adapter nos exploitants
futurs exploitants futur c'est c'est
salvateur la plur disciplinité donc
c'est c'est une évolution pédagogique
que j'assume et après on va continuer en
discuter évidemment avec avec les uns et
les autres parce que je suis très
attaché à ça sur le sujet 2ème question
sur sur ce que disait la sénatrice
billon sur les MFR alors je moi je
préempte pas un échec quand je commence
juste la
discussion je je commence la discussion
budgétaire avec les MFR et c'est normal
qu'il y ait une discussion au moment où
je débute je dis pas bon alors
maintenant qu'on va échouer non parce
que je il peut arriver même qu'on arrive
à trouver un terrain d'entente avec les
MFR c'est un élément très important mais
il y a une baisse constance des effet
ça c'est aussi un fait qui s'impose à
nous et donc faut qu'on travaille à la
fois parce que c'est un réseau qui est
très important le réseau des MFR c'est
un réseau d'avir territorialement vous
le savez aussi bien que moi très présent
y compris dans une maille très fine dans
des communes qui sont de petite taille
donc c'est un élément très important et
donc il faut qu'on arrive à à repenser
avec les MFR c'est pas une question
budgétaire seulement c'est pas une
question c'est une question de comment
on reconsolide dans notre appareil de
formation l'appareil de formation de
l'enseignement école il est formidable
parce qu'il est très divers dans ses
formes et dans sa géographie euh mais
donc on a besoin de travailler avec la
MFR et donc c'est leur permettre de
continuuer à exister et d'être une
compésante de l'enseignement agricole
auprès des familles on sait à quel point
ils sont formidables aussi en terme
euh comment dirais-je d'inclusivité et
et et alors pour le coup là on est sur
quelque chose où il y a moins de jeune
et le budget est égal il a pas baissé
hein bon depuis des années donc il faut
qu'on se repose la question de
l'adéquation des moyen je pense
que la sénatrice billon pourra pourra le
comprendre alors après je finis juste
sur l'aventure du vivant j'ai
l'impression d'entendre ça toutes les
années je me demande si mes
prédécesseurs ont pas entendu la même
chose c'est il est bien votre bus mais
on le voit pas oui alors il y en a qu'un
ou deux ça peut pas tourner comme ça on
essaie d'être moi je l'ai vu à tour je
peux vous le dire alors c'est peut-être
qu'il le déplace avec le ministre pour
lui faire
plaisir que c'est un peukin notre
affaire mais je crois pas seulement
euh je crois que ça alors il y a pas que
mais je trouve que ce concept est un
concept où on va vers plutôt que venez
vers nous c'est on va vers les gens on
va sur les lieux où il y a du monde à
tour 45000 visiteurs combien même j'en
j'en attrape si je peux dire que s j'ai
fait j'ai j'ai fait quelque chose en
plus c'est très original de format parce
qu'il y a les apprenants les enseignants
donc j'entends la remarque mais je je je
trouve que c'est plutôt quelque chose
qui a fonctionné et qui a fonctioné
utilement pour faire connaître les
métiers et pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse avancer sur la question du
recrutement de jeunes parce que ça c'est
un élément évidemment très important
alors ensuite il y a une questions
sur c'est la sénatrice mon sur la
question de la pluridisciplinarité vous
m'avez demandé si on comptait
généralisé non mais en même temps il
faut en faire voilà c'est c'est là aussi
on est toujours un peu dans un système
français c'est pas ce que vous avez dit
hein on dit c'est l'un ou c'est l'autre
non il faut la plurdiscipline é mais pas
que de la plurie disciplinarité voilà
donc c'est pas une
volonté les affaires alors lycée
maritime vous avez vous-même permis au
ministre de l'Agriculture que je suis de
dégager en touche mais je vais le faire
sincèrement donc pas en touche vraiment
sur le ministère qui en charge je vais
en parler avec mon collègue Berville ça
je prends l'engagement devant vous parce
que ça pour le coup je reconnais
volontiers que ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
dans mes compétent je reviendrai tout à
l'heure sur les questions des
AES il me semble que c'est un un élément
global que vous avez évoqué monsieur le
sénateur vous avez évoqué la la question
de il faut il faut le budget se regarde
à la hauteur de
l'ambition alors s'il se regarde à la
hauteur de l'ambition plus de 2
milliards en 2 ans sur un budget qui
était à 5 je vous laisse entirer les
conclusions il me semble que c'est à la
hauteur des ambitions voilà après on
peut en discuter sur le
fond mais je suis pas complètement
d'accord avec vous néanmoins je pense
que il faut il faut des moyens mais il
faut aussi une stratégie et un cap
l'ambition c'est pas que des moyens ça
vient traduire si vous dites j'ai une
ambition que vous mettez pas de moyens
c'est un peu vain mais alors là les
moyens on peut pas dire qu'ils y sont
pas et par ailleurs le pacte et la loi
d'orientation permettront de dire aussi
le cap au travers d'un objet aussi que
vous avez sous les yeux qui est l'objet
de la de la planification donc je pense
que c'est un élément
important de de de rappeler ça parce que
je pense que c'est un élément qui permet
aussi de dire que je crois qu'on a rien
n'est jamais parfait vous m'entendrez je
donne assez rarement dans le registre de
l'autosatisfaction je suis pas sûr que
ça me vienne un jour mais je pense qu'on
a plutôt une trajectoire on a un cap et
plutôt une vraie trajectoire budgétaire
sur sur sur en plus un process triénal
comme vous savez budgétairement on a
aussi des réflexions triénal il me
semble c'est un élément important
là-dessus
euh alors la recette monsieur il y a des
éléments je reviendrai tout à mais la
recette monsieur le sénateur lever
m'ainterrogé sur la recette pour
arrié il y a une culture d'engagement
incontestable et puis il y a quelque
chose d'une ambiance enseignement
agricole qui est particulière je ça
m'ériterai de faire des études
sociologiques mais il y a quelque chose
de particulier dans l'enseignement
agricole je dis au passage d'ailleur
vous me disiez comment on attire c'est
vous qui me posez la question comment on
attire des gens qui viennent de la
ville 60 % d'internat dans
l'enseignement agricole he donc c'est
bien quelque chose sur lequel on
travaille qui existe c'est hyper
puissant et je prétends moi que dans les
processus pédagogique l'internat n'est
pas un mauvais une mauvaise brique sans
faire de jeux mot qui participe de
l'inclusivité des élèves du suivi des
élèves en continu que ceux qui ont
besoin de sortir de chez eux qui sont
désocialisés et qui retrouvent là
quelque chose du l'ordre du lien d'une
petite société qui se
crée et donc ça marche plutôt et donc
oui si on veut attirer des jeunes de la
ville vers la campagne pour faire une
caricature il faut qu'on continue cette
politique active de l'internat parce que
c'est un moyen
d'attirer faut qu'on cherche aussi le le
le je pense que le plus difficile c'est
comment vous faites sortir un
élève qui est en î de France proche
Paris et proche banlieu pour aller dans
une exploitation
agricole ça c'est et c'est ça ce qu'on
va travailler au travers du PACT parce
que c'est évidemment il y a la
logistique évidemment c'est compqu parce
que comme on se le dit vous l'avez dit
certains d'entre vous j'ai pas
d'agriculteur au pas de la
porte donc c'est c'est et donc c'est
moins ça veut dire que vous faites par
nature moins de sortie quand vous vivez
dans une commune ou dans un village oou
l'agriculteur au pas de la porte tous
les matins vous le voyez donc on peut
pas faire ça en ville donc il faut qu'on
construise quelque
chose avec les avec l'Éducation
nationale d'ailleurs puisqueune partie
relève de l'éducation nationale non
agricole il me semble que voilà c'est
c'est ça et puis de il faut que les
agriculteurs et qu'on facilite parfois
des réglementation comment dirais-je
tatillonne l'ouverture des fermes aux
agriculteurs il y a 400000 exploitations
en
France euh les 400000 n n'accueille pas
aujourd'hui mais déjà on aurait la
moitié qui accueillerait ça ferait du
monde en fait voyez ce que je veux dire
alors c'est un peu de temps hein donc il
faut une forme de reconnaissance d'une
manière ou d' autre je parle pas
financière c'est pas le sujet je pense
pour les agriculteurs il faut qu'on
aménage pour que ça puisse se faire et
et donc c'est comme ça qu'on va essayer
de construire me semble-t-il la question
euh
les AESA sur la cédisation reprise
effective en gestion et en paye par le
ministère de l'Agriculture pardon
j'avais pas répondu à cette question
mais je fais le
paquet ça nécessite d'harmoniser des
dossiers c'est à peu près 400 personnes
donc c'est pas un tout petit sujet on a
remis des moyens l'an dernier d'ailleurs
au ministère sur ces questions de
gestion des ressources humaines parce
que c'était aussi une difficulté que
nous rencontrions et donc on va on va
essayer sereinement et je le dis avec
sérénité moi-même et en transparence
pour les agents de faire ça dans le
premier semestre 2024 vous avez raison
c'est un élément
important que que que vous me posez que
qu'il faut qu'on essaie de résoudre dans
dans la perspective de l'année 2024
euh la madame la sénatrice brelle vous
m'avez interrogé sur le taux de
couverture des postes à la rentrée c'est
99 %
globalement je ne dis pas que c'est
simple je ne dis pas que ça sera facile
demain donc je préviens que c'est on a
un sujet d'attractivité
mais le PACT enseignant le sens qu'on
donne aux choses la loi d'orientation
enfin tout ça doit essayer de montrer ce
qu'on fait dans l'enseignement agricole
qui soit pas caricaturé ou caricatur
parce que deux caricature l'essentiel
des métiers auquel on forme ne sont pas
des métiers d'IGN d'exploitant agricole
il y a plein de métiers dans
l'enseignement on connait pas les 200
métiers et j'ai quand même besoin de
d'exploitant agricole par ailleurs je
rappelle que dans l'enseignement
agricole 10 % seulement des jeunes sont
ont des parents
agriculteurs et je crois 40 50 ou 60 %
ne sont pas issu du monde agricole
c'estàdire en
proximité donc c'est 70 plutôt 70 pardon
euh donc c'est une réalité qui existe
déjà d'une certaine façon mais il faut
qu'on travaille là-dessus on travaille
là-dessus parce que ça amène plutôt à
des métiers qui sont pas principalement
exploitant agricole encore que l'autre
jour j'ai rencontré des jeunes et des
jeunes femmes je signale que c'est un un
enseignement qui est assez bon en parité
contrairement à ce qu'on croit de Têt 45
% de femmes 46 directeur est plus précis
que moi mais c'est normal il est
directeur et et 54 donc si je sais faire
les calculs ça c'est les mat qui
sommeille en moi c'est normal il est
ministre c'est normal il est aussi
directeur mais c'est c'est un
enseignement c'est un enseignement qui
est très inclusif en T de réussi je le
disais dans mon propos liuminaire mais
très paritaire et c'est une bonne
nouvelle contrairement aux images aussi
répandues alors un peu genré si on peut
dire en terme de
profession n'est pas assez paritaire en
forêt par exemple
et c'est dommage que j'ai besoin de
monde en forêt vraiment jeir besoin de
profil en forêt donc évidemment mais de
ce point de vue là c'est un travail donc
on a besoin t de couverture est
important mais on a besoin de travailler
sur l'attractivité long terme c'est le
PACT enseignement c'est la question du
niveau de recrutement qu'on a évoqué
tout à l'heure il me semble que c'est un
élément important laatce évoqué la
question qu'est-ce qu'on enseigne estce
qu'on enseigne bien oui oui oui je vous
assure vous
regarderiez der les référentiels on est
vraiment
alors j'essaie de pas être que il faut
qu'on enseigne tout ce que sera
l'agriculture de
demain le bio l'agro l'agroécologie
c'est pour tout le monde parce que je
pense que l'agroécologie ça s'impose à
tout le monde mais ça c'est c'est c'est
fait he
déjà c'est c'est c'est une volonté
collective après moi je pense qu'on a
besoin doter de doter nos jeunes qui
vont s'installer d'une d'une d'une
palette d'outils parce que la vie qu'ils
ont aujourd'hui avec le règlement
climatique je peux pas leur garantir
comment il sera dans 30 ans donc on leur
donne des principes de base
l'agroécologie est un principe de base
l'adaptation la capacité la mobilité
l'agilité c'est dire que je je ne peux
plus garantir ce qu'on a pu garantir
pendant une quarantaine d'années à un
jeune que voilà ton climat voilà ta
production voilà ton marché et voilà le
monde géopolitique que tu
connais malheureusement nous sommes
rentrés dans les grands temps de
l'incertitude donc dans ces cas-là il y
a deux solutions soit on a PE on se
replie soit on dit je vais te donner des
outils et des moyens d'être agile et de
pouvoir naviguer dans
cettecertitude et par exemple dans la
question de l'agroécologie on fait
partie voilà après dire aujourd'hui
seulement c'est le bio ou autre c'est
compliqué parce que voyez il y a 3 ans
tout le monde aurait dire aurait dit va
au bio va au bio aujourd'hui on a un
tout petit sujet de de consommation sur
le bio donc et donc voilà là il me
semble que et donc on va travailler
d'ailleurs sur la question des
compétences entre guillemets
psychosociales
pour naviguer dans ce monde
d'incertitude y compris parce que il y a
beaucoup de malêtrre dans le monde
agricole et il faut qu'on les prépare à
cette incertitude il faut qu'on les
prépare aussi au monde dans lequel ils
vont évoluer qui donneent le sentiment
parfois d'être hostile après c'est le
boulot du ministre de l'agriculture et
de nous tous me semble-t-il si vous me
permettez cette expression de faire en
sorte qu'on explique les métiers de
l'agriculture parce que pour attirer des
gens si je lis juste les articles qui
qui explique comment marche
l'agriculture ça va pas attirer beaucoup
de jeunes hein
ou ce que je lis sur Twitter
c'est quel jeune va venir j'étais devant
les forestiers avant de venir vous
rejoindre les actions c'est c'est des
c'est c'est l'image qu'on donne des
forestiers c'est la coupras la
tronçonneuse alors vraiment on dire ah
bah c'est incroyable on arrive pas à
recruter des forestiers bah oui c'est
normal sauf que il faudrait expliquer
qu'il y a des gens qui plantent il y a
des gens qui observent il y a des gens
qui conseillent il y a des gens qui
coupent du bois parce qu'il faut mettre
ça sur les tables que sur lesquel nous
sommes installés et que tout ça
participe d'un cercle donc c'est ça
aussi je pense qu'on a
besoin je je fais la la digression par
rapport au psychosocial on a besoin mais
si on veut installer des jeunes et si on
veut installer des gens dans le secteur
agricole globalement on a besoin de
valoriser les métiers vous avez quand
même des enfants aujourd'hui qui n'osent
pas dire que leurs parents travaillent
dans des
abattoirs c'est c'est pas un métier
interdit c'est pas un métier honteux il
en faut des gens il bien content qu' a
des gens qui travaillent dans les
abattoirs et on va manquer des gens dans
les abattoirs pour être salarié on va
manquer de gens dans les abattoirs pour
diriger les
abattoirs donc il va bien falloir aussi
qu'on dis ça tranquillement
pacifiquement aussi pacifiquement je
peux le faire mais il me semble que
c'est un élément important j'ajoute
madame la sénatrice que nous travaillons
aussi beaucoup dans les lycées agricoles
ça fera l'OG un joint un peu avec les la
question des des régions on travaille
beaucoup sur les objectifs des galimes
les éco citoyens on est très avancé sur
ces sujets là dans les notamment parce
que l'Internal permet un peu plus
facilement parce qu'il y a des tempanks
qui sont réservés sans doute à ça et
donc je pense que nous sommes plutôt
bien avancés sur ces questionsl euh sur
la question de des médecins euh la
recrutement de médecin je sais plus qui
m'a posé la question enfin bref
euh on est bien dans la trajectoire avec
plus 20 ETP pour transorter globalement
le dispositif 15 po alors c'est vrai
qu'on a un sujet en permanence mais ça
c'est le sujet démographie médicale il
touche le donc on a un sujet alors on
vous fera passer les chiffres peut-être
d'ici la séance sur les éléments de ce
que sont les effectifs de médecin je
poursuis pardon pour pas être trop long
euh la pvoir pvoir des postes je l'ai
répondu à la sénatrice Brusselles
mutualisation vous avez dit enfin est-ce
que chacun cultive sa différence donc il
faut être j'essaie de respecter la
biodiversité de d'écosystème
d'enseignement après tout après tout ça
fonctionne pas
mal première des mutualisation c'est que
ces deux écosystèmes dialogue se
comprennent y compris pour dire tu
pourrais aller dans l'enseignement
agricole ou tu pourrais aller dans
l'enseignement général il me semble que
euh premier élément de mutualisation
pour créer faut créer un climat de
dialogueors il existe he mais le
renforcer c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait en
primaire qu'est-ce qu'on fait au
collège pour que ce dialogue dans les
entre les équipes de de ces deux
éducations si je peux dire deux modes
d'enseignement puissent se parler à date
je je dis pas que ça suffirait à mon
bonheur mais c'est je trouve que ça
serait déjà pas mal il me semble qu'on
puisse le faire que vous m'avez
interrogé alors c'est madame Danielle je
crois sur la question de nouvelle école
vétérinaire euh madame la cénatrice
alors c'est un c'est la deuxième
promotion qui est accueillie donc
difficile d'avoir un peu de recul
deuxième élément reconnaissons qu'en
France cétait formidable nous n'avions
pas augmenté les effectifs permettant de
fabriquer si je peux dire de former des
vétérinaires une très grande partie des
vétérinaires français allit qui en
Roumanie qui en Belgique résultat on a
une démographie vétérinaire désastreuse
et nous avons décidé d'inverser la
tendance donc on va former le plus
possible de gens dans les écoles
vétérinaires existantes publi par
ailleurs et on voit bien que
l'enseignement agricole le fait assez
bien que est une école privée qui se
soit créée en Normandie puisque c'est là
qu' s'est créé ça contribue à l'objectif
que nous nous sommes fixés dans les
écoles existantes et dans cette école
complémentaire de former 75% de
vétérinaire en plus d'ici 2030 et ça
c'est assez empirique parce qu'il suffit
d'ouvrir jeux dire et on va on a déjà 40
% de vet formé en plus depuis 2017 donc
là pour le coup j'ai des faits là et des
statistiques après on aura un deuxième
sujet mais ça c'est moins votre sujet
mais ça va être le bienen c'est où
est-ce qu'ils
vont parce que j'aurais besoin qu'ils
aill un tout petit peu en
rural pour faire pas que de la canine
puisque c'est comme ça qu'on dit
maintenant je suis spécialiste de ces
questions et on dit la canine et la
rurale et donc 40 % faut qu'il soit
plutôt c'est comme les médecins en
général d'ailleurs à quel endroit ils
vont donc on a un sujet d'attractivité
territoriale mais ça c'est un deuxième
sujet et donc ça ne vient
pas se soustraire à l'engagement du
gouvernement ça vient compléter parce
que sinon on va pas y arriver hein et
donc cette école est la bienvenue et
nous avons une culture publque privée
plutôt solide dans l'enseignement
agricole euh plutôt apaisé entre les
deux écosystèmes et moi je m'en félicite
parce qu'après tout ça permet d'avancer
et ça contribue à l'objectif euh
qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié de dire euh
donc l'évaluation viendra après ah les
bourses oui pardon les bourses vous non
mais vous avez raison j'essaie de
répondre aux questions comme vous
l'aurez remarqué euh comme je passe sur
la fiche sur les questions des régions
je reviens aux bourses
euh euh oui on travaille plutôt bien
avec les régions alors les régions
qu'est-ce qu'on partage on partage les
questions de bâtiments on partage la
question des personnels c'est on
travaille bien sur les sujets des Galim
par exemple avec les régions je crois
qu'on a plutôt on a besoin de renforcer
avec elles les régions euh le travail y
compris euh euh de détection
d'encouragement euh et ce d'autant que
les régions ont une part de la
compétence agricole il me semble que
c'est un élément euh très important sur
cette sur cette questionl puisque la la
question y compris du la loi et du pacte
d'orientation
euh ça va être la question d'avec les
régions de trouver les voies et moyens
d'encourager par l'investissement
d'incourager par l'orientation les
choses et donc pas de difficulté sur les
bourses euh en fait c'est un
guichet donc euh bah ça baisse quand il
y a moins de demande ça augmente quand
il y a plus de
demande je peux pas vous dire mieux sil
a plus de besoins il y aura plus
d'argent s'il y a plus de besoin il y
aura plus d'argent je peux pas vraiment
vous dire mieux mon moi-même je suis à
penser que voilà c'est comme ça
franchement je pense qu'on est plutôt je
pense que c'est plutôt pas mal parce que
c'est donc c'est pas les critères qui
viennent changer les choses qu'est-ce
que j'ai oublié de dire les questions de
sécurité qui ont été évoqué par le
sénateur on n pas eu de fait plus avéré
que dans d'autres établissements
plusutôt moins il me semble-t-il on a on
a évidemment des mesures bah on s'aligne
sur les mesures enfin je veux dire les
établissement d'enseignement agricole
sont soumis aux mêmes règles aux même
vigilance à la même vigilance du
ministre sur les questions le respect
des grands principes compris ceux de
laïcité quand les faits sont signalés
c'est tout le monde passe à la même
toise en nement agricole qu'ailleurs et
donc il SEM que c'est un élément il me
semble que c'est un élément important de
dire voilà je pas d'autre chose à dire à
ce à ce stade que le fait que nous
sommes nous-mêmes très respectueux et
très soucieux du fait qu'on respecte
dans l'enseignement agricole aussi
quelque chose alors après comme vous
avez en plus des élèves qui sont pour
beaucoup en internat vous voyez bien que
ça facilite aussi le travail permanent
de pédagogie et d'ex citation et la
relation compris avec les familles le
système internat est favorable de ce
point de vue voilà monsieur le Président
et mes monur ministre la question sur
l'apprentissage entre le prébac et le
postback
ou est-ce que ça se développe autant en
prébac PO plutôt partout voilà jusqu'à
ingénieur public on a 200 CFPP public
donc oui ça se fait là sembleil voilà
merci monsieur le ministre pour vos
réponses très précises j'essay et et
nous aurons à analyser le rapport euh de
notre rapporteur dans dans quelques
jours cétait important de vous
auditionner bien sûr avant merci
beaucoup
merci tac tac merci bien cette année